la rivière des mille îles au nord de
laval la pêche
l'observation de la faune des balades en
canoë ou en kayak ce qu'on appelle les b
you lie vers des mails et c'est un
complexe d'archipels de milieux naturels
un joyau aux yeux de guy garand qui
dirige le conseil régional de
l'environnement et un spectacle
quotidien pour cette résidente qui se
sait privilégié
j'arrive ici j'avais 12 1 ça fait 48 ans
que je suis ici c'était bernage son look
leur bébé pizza qui sont couchés qui
s'est plaint de kayak et canoë pédalo
mais depuis quelques semaines elle a
peur que tout change
j'ai la vue directement sur l'île qui il
parle de faire un hôtel de six étages et
un sport qui plein de choses je pars de
la tranquillité le temps que ça
construit après on va servir et support
un complexe hôtelier de ce point de tout
de six étages on veut le voir dupont
l'abord on va voir de partout c'est une
honte pour le territoire de laval
le projet qui suscite des inquiétudes
concerne l'île gagnon la seule résidence
pour l'instant c'est l'ancien manoir de
céline dion une île privée achetée 10
millions de dollars en 2016
c'est lui qui habite ici en semaine et
qui pilote le projet de développement
dans nos rêves les plus fous
ce serait d'avoir vraiment un projet
exemplaire au niveau de
l'écoresponsabilité l'hôtel devient le
coeur du projet ou est-ce que ça serait
une annexe à un hôtel donc probablement
une l'automne hôtel serait construit à
côté puis aurait probablement des
habitations permanentes qui pourraient
jumelées puis connectez par le dessous
selon les esquisses du projet on parle
de 700 unités de logement 1500 places de
stationnement souterrain et plusieurs
accès aux berges pour un coût estimé à
800 millions de dollars
on est rendu à l'étape de
l'acceptabilité sociale de présenter le
projet d'aller chercher les formations
le pouls des citoyens et des
organisations alentours de l'île gagnon
la ville mène aussi un sondage jusqu'à
demain auprès des résidents du secteur
ian l'a remplie et a dit tout le mal
qu'ils en pensent
tu peux contre le projet parce que c'est
dans ma cour au contraire je suis contre
le projet c'est bien parce que ça n'a
pas de sens à l'endroit où il propose en
ce moment
si le projet c'était à l'espace moment
aussi où quelque chose ce serait
probablement un super projet certains
organismes qui ont été approchés pour
consultation déplore la manière de faire
du promoteur voulu me faire signer une
confidentialité l'aide de
confidentialité pour le projet de l'île
gagnon qui me muselet pour 60 mois que
j'ai pas le droit de sortir sur le
projet une fois que j'ai signé ça parce
qu'il voulait me présenter son projet en
2019 et ça fait déjà des années qui
parle de 3 personnes vous en a parlé
l'avait semblerait que ça fait trois ans
qu'on est au courant du projet
ni la ville de laval ni la conseillère
du secteur centre aux noms ont voulu
participer à ce reportage
en 2017 laval pensait donner un statut
de protection à l'île gagnon
l'entreprise derrière le projet olymbec
a réussi à obtenir que le secteur reste
à vocation urbaine et selon le zonage
actuel
le terrain est constructible pour des
maisons on comprend que ça serait
toujours mieux des parcs naturellement
au loto ce lieu des parcs
mais ce n'est privé puis médard faut
trouver des compromis on n'a pas le
choix de disposer de ce bien immobilier
dont qu'est ce qu'on ferait un
développement de maisons unifamiliales
ça serait un gâchis mais probable hamac
on n'aurait pas le choix guy garand lui
ira sur l'eau samedi prochain pour une
manifestation silencieuse autour de
l'île lui qui a plutôt l'habitude
d'élever la voix
franchement un calage trouve ça frustre
un qu'on laisse la responsabilité aux
citoyens aux organismes de toujours se
battent pour protéger notre milieu
naturel notre environnement de qualité
prix
et pour sa qualité de vie madame babin
comme beaucoup d'autres attend les
résultats du sondage avec impatience ici
mathieu prost radio-canada laval